We're not talking about external codes of conduct here,
although we could.
We're not.
The wickedness that's being described is the act of you doing something that you
know to be wrong,
period.
You know,
and you may do something you don't know if it's wrong or not.
That isn't a sort of thing that we're talking about and we're not talking about
the things that you do that are right are there that other people think are
wrong.
We're not talking about those either.
We're talking about those things that you consciously do,
although you know them to be wrong yourself.
And that's the things that seem to get people into the most trouble in these
stories.
And I believe that to be the case.
I think that's very accurate.
Psychologically it's amazing because I see this all the time.
If you do something wrong and it's because you're ignorant,
you don't know better,
it's,
it doesn't go well for you.
That's the case.
But if you do something wrong and you know it's wrong,
the punishment is,
is manifold.
And I think the reason for that,
I think the reason for that is because that makes you cane.
It means you betray your own ideal,
right?
If you just don't know,
well,
you haven't betrayed your ideal,
you're just not together.
You maybe you're even willfully blind,
but if you do something you know to be wrong,
then you've betrayed your own ideal and that lands you came says to God one once
Kayden destroys able,
he says,
I cannot bear my punishment.